واكدت المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس الامن
لدا توماس جرينفيلد ان مشروع القرار الذي
وزعته الجزائر الاربعاء والذي يطالب بوقف
اطلاق نار فوري في غزه قد يعرض المفاوضات
الحساسه بشان الهدنه المقترحه للخطر وقالت
المندوبه الامريكيه ان على مجلس الامن
الدولي ان يضمن ان اي اجراء يتخذه في
الايام المقبله يزيد الضغط على حماس لقبول
الاقتراح حسب
تعبيرها
على المجلس الالتزام بضمان ان اي اجراء
نتخذه في الايام المقبله يزيد الضغط على
حماس لقبول الاقتراح ونعتقد ان مشروع
القرار الذي تقدمت به الجزائر لا يحقق هذه
الغايه بل على العكس من ذلك فان مشروع
القرار هذا يمكن ان يعرض المفاوضات
الحساسه للخطر وان يعرقل الجهود
الدبلوماسيه الشميله والمستمره لتامين
اطلاق سراح الرهائن وتامين هدنه مطوله
يحتاج اليها المدنيون الفلسطينيون وعمال
الاغا بشده الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكن لهذا
المجلس ويجب عليه فعله هو دعم القرارين
الانسانيين الذين اعتمدناه بالفعل